I don't have a lust of money and I don't
have a I actually don't even have a love
of money I don't buy it to like yeah I'm
gonna miss like nah feel like I got a
lot left everybody got something to be
thankful for even though homeless man if
he wanted to he could be like y'all
breathing today like I'm not actually
good at being resourceful I'm getting
better he's a rapper record producer and
songwriter he received a nomination for
Best New Artist at the 54th Grammy
Awards he's the first rapper in 25 years
to have a platinum-selling album without
any guest appearances he's Jay Cole and
here's my take on his top ten rules for
success number one is my personal
favorite I make sure to stick around
although to the end for a special bonus
clip do you want to make a lot of money
I don't want to make a lot of money but
but that's only for safety purposes like
I don't have a lust of money and I don't
have a I actually don't even have a love
of money like you got people I don't
know these people you know they're my
friends and they also rappers that I
know they love money they addicted to
getting money and that's cool too
because that's what makes some of the
most successful businessmen I don't love
money like that I love the comfort and
the safety and the ability to retire my
mama like if there's a problem with my
brother that my father has a problem I
like that feeling of being able to
provide so that's the thing I do love
about money but to tell you the truth
what makes me the happiest is the music
working on the music I'm in the studio
right now with Elle Varner we I'm
producing for another person that makes
me happy that makes me way more happy
than getting a check my album comes out
the response is amazing that makes me
way more happy if I write a song I mean
letting us down a song off my album when
I made that song the feeling that I made
that I had I thought made that song is
way more important to me than making
money you know but yeah of course I
wanna make a lot of money so I can be
safe just a case something I needed I
got to buy into my own height
you know like I'm grateful for the
reactions and the appreciation but I
don't buy it to like yeah I'm gonna mid
like not feel like I got a lot left like
I got a I'm gonna be here for years like
being hot in 2013 it's cool you know and
being and critically acclaimed in 2013
is cool but like what about 2020 like
where am I going to be I don't want to
be making a documentary 20 years from
now talking about like this as if it was
the end I want to still be present and
still be making music I want to be like
you know Bruce Springsteen or something
like making songs that are relevant if a
tragedy happens make a song in this room
and I can just put it out in people you
know people know I'm still speaking for
them I want to be like that I have my
art always appreciated
what was going through your mind when
everything was just falling apart and
and you don't even know like what the
but you don't even know what to do and
basically everything was just falling
apart and you just trying to find a way
like what was going through your mind
did you ever think like damn what if
this doesn't happen for me you know my
mind never worked like that in the
beginning we're like when I wasn't on I
never had those thoughts but I can't
relate to that only because they came a
point after my first album was already
out where I started like really getting
down on myself like man like I really
like I really just dropped the ball man
like this didn't go how I wanted to go
like I can't come out how four saw
myself coming out and I was really
getting down to myself and it felt it
really did feel way more and everybody
else's look at me like crazy had a
number when I'm in the country you got
to go at Grammy nominee and I'm not
seeing or appreciate a that so what I
can say is you have to look you have to
stop looking at what you don't have and
what's not happening for you and start
appreciating like what you do actually
have like my man you got on nice wife's
like your hat is fresh like you're in
New York City is the land of opportunity
you know to me you could look at guy I'm
sure you got maybe a girlfriend like
there's a lot of thing your family a lot
of things to be grateful for and that's
the only way you can climb out of like a
place of focusing on what you don't have
is by focusing on like man what do I
have to be thankful for everybody got
son to be thankful for even a homeless
man if you wanted to we can be like
y'all or even today like
you know to me like my arms work my legs
work you can start very small and out of
that it's gonna dis a process but that's
how you can get about like a negative
space like that music is my passion man
production besides the actual art of rap
and I want a lot I want to accomplish on
the production in in the production side
I would love to try my hand and acting
my mother's an actress she tells me all
the time and she thinks he sent me she's
been telling me that for years boy
you're an actor I'm telling you she
always tells me you know so I would love
to try my hand at daddy I mean you use
your accents I mean you probably could
call Will Smith and get some advice okay
that's very I could do you do this I
have the connection at least to do that
I don't I guess because I'm not
passionate about it yet it's just a
thought but hopefully when I when I
become passionate or when I take it
serious I would use that car you just
gave me the car to use it gave me the
idea for it so but yeah I do have access
I'm not actually good at being
resourceful I'm getting better that's
another thing to be a great businessman
I think you have to be incredibly
resourceful I'm new to business period I
never was good with money
so having money is new to me and
therefore using my resources being a
great businessman is it's new to me
no reason I was in New York was cuz I
wanted to do music so school was just
like in my eyes school was just like the
temporary thing that I was doing while I
was chasing a dream so then about my
sophomore junior years when I was like
you know what wait like I got to refocus
and reship my energy to the music thing
that's when I was weren't going on a
rampage I probably it up every n art on
MySpace but I sent like I sent these
same people messages you know like
through MySpace or whatever card that
office I called it up is like yeah you
reached Darryl Jones for Atlantic
Records pleasing the message at the
beach yeah I left the longest rap on his
voicemail
I just rapped on his boys wet and I
think I might have left my like my
number at the end-of-summer idea
but like because I never got called back
you know I wouldn't even cause my back
to did that but it just just to show you
the type of it I was doing I was trying
anything and everything so time was
running out it was coming close to
graduation and I hadn't really made any
major moves but I was always felt like
it was coming like it was coming so man
it took home after I graduated to still
took another year and a half after I
graduated to actually get to Jake and
get all that stuff rolling but you know
it's all the process man you just gotta
just keep God believe have faith I
always felt like it's right around the
corner that's why I just kept going
let's talk about having faith in that in
the leaf how did you remain at that
point I don't I got strong faith in what
you doing yeah I don't cuz I felt like
for year this is years of work and years
of me knowing that this is when I first
dudes I think when you believe in
yourself do you know that you just know
so even when you're working a part-time
job and you get paid $8 an hour and
you're like yeah I don't want to be here
you know if you truly know what's coming
you don't mind doing that because you
know it's temporary this is temporary
and it's a temporary sacrifice for what
I want to end up doing so that's what
kept me going because I never questioned
it'll always like well I'm closer I'm
closer today I'm closer than I was
yesterday and that mentality that's
gonna get you through it if not that's
what anything that's not even just music
that's life period and to expand on that
you believe that you we control your
destiny where your life goal is how
important is that please I want I want
you to tell the people out there inspire
them the story like how you came up to
the where you are right now certain
things happen in your life do you have
no control over but life is about how
you react to those things and handle
those things and those I don't know
those occurrences or whatever so I
absolutely believe that you chewy like
where you want to go what you want to be
and it's up to you to get that as a
rapper there's very few greats that I
studied and I still continue to study
and knowledge is obviously one of them
is obvious I really had his lyrics
printed on my wall they just had a site
was called hola original hip-hop lyrics
whatever dot-com or archive yeah
somebody know and then you put
I would print these joints out and I
would I would print them up and hang
them up on my wall and literally if you
walk in my room you might be I was wrong
this kid I'm standing at or later just
reading the lyrics because I wanted to
know what it was like to be that good
you know to me like and I was rapping at
the time so I wanted to know and it was
my goal to be that good I wanted to
somehow try to master the style I felt
like if I read it enough if I listen I
used to go to sleep listening in to I am
you know to me and people be sleeping on
that I might be trying to tell them that
man is spitting on for real on that
album I used to go to Sleepless in that
album because I wanted to try to master
the style if I could you know I mean you
can't master that style but I felt about
you how you probably felt about rock
camera okay Naji rapper whoever it was
that you looked at like the god that's
how I felt any musician period any
artist I think just absolutely do what's
in your heart
period say what's on your mind speak
what's in your heart and how you really
feel when you're trying to be something
else me trying to fit into what's going
on it's like you kind of stray away from
your path a little bit and sometimes you
want to expand your style and like grow
and that's always good but like never
veer too far from who you are you know
as a as a person the best way to
establish yourself on the Internet is to
uh is to start small once again be
humble approach twenties but first of
all you got mention your music is
practicing
do amusing but once you feel like your
music is truly correct stay humble start
small go to like some of the smaller
blogs yeah yeah you know they don't get
as many history there now rice but maybe
they'll post if they like it you know
Saturday DC to PC and you know like part
of me dude and people like smaller blogs
it up greater perfection you know maybe
if they fill in you got a shot like they
put it up there's a way better change
that the big blogs are pick it up
especially after seeing it you know if
perfection picks it up it may be DC to
BC puts it up maybe part of me do with
it that is three getting more small
applause that still have good followers
that upon your sort of big applause like
a two doughboys might pick it up man and
then after they bring it on that so
that's the best way to just start that
big dream and then just start small and
no but the Internet is not the end-all
be-all mass there's a lot more to go
expensive going into a club with no
eighteen thousand dollars on average
back like some people we know know I've
seen that that's thing that a live in
person I can't do that I don't have I'm
too afraid of losing of going back over
there
to ever blow money without thinking
about it there's a song of my album
called chain and a and and this is the
type of artist I am and this album is
like this to a tee most rappers are
gonna say
paid $100,000 for the chain and they're
gonna show you the change that's gonna
song I paid $100,000 what a change
I paid $100,000 but it's change
paid $100,000 but a change and that's
their whole song and they got the whole
song to tell you how they spend $100,000
per chain
my song is going to tell you like my
thought process before I paid all this
money for some jewelry which was it is
really it was like this like oh my god
like yo yes do I want it yes how much
people pay that and then my internal
conversation is like yo you know better
you definitely know you know better than
to spend this type of money but do you
want is it worth it what's the
investment where when I'm on stage is
going really good so you can say it's
for your career man it does look nice
how much and it's a more internal
conversation you know what you can do
with all that money
you know who lives you can change with
that type of money you spin out and
change so that other song was I spent
$100,000 on a chain I spending 100 and
then in my song you get all of these
internal thoughts that let me to finally
be like all right here you go
and I wrote the check or at least I gave
him my car you know to me but I gave you
my thought process first before I just
spent $100,000 on that change a cold
value-added we are even when we own the
world is constantly pumping us with
images right about what life should be
about constant selling is what life is
about what should be alone in the States
is called the American dream I don't
know what the economy but I know y'all
got it and I know it includes the saying
what is it always a clue
a lot of money a big-ass house a
brand-new car and a wife that's like not
even everything possible right that's
what it tells me to be happy even though
the world is set up so that 99% of us
gender actors but we idolize the people
that do have it we say we watch and we
go oh my god a life looks so perfect
look at the door oh my god and I came
here tonight to tell y'all I was the
same group so that was sitting down
watching like oh my God we're so turnt
it must be nice
I'm a cool kid and then I went you got
this but when I got there I'm telling
y'all up close a person who don't feel
like home right now and I'm coming back
and tell y'all all it's all this is fun
it is not all supportive it's not
relaxed
how do I know that I know that because
right now it's a man he got millions of
dollars he got a billion bottles he's
measured right but you got a family that
come from where we come from worse
conditions than where we come from we
could afford a ticket to the show
tonight if they wanted but yet somehow
they got more happiness enjoy any life
right now in this man whatever happen is
how was that possible how is that even
possible
that everything we thought we needed he
got is Israel and they have nothing and
they got happiness what do they have a
tall guy who's that
you smile
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this for you too because Keri
Butler asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur you I made a profile next
leave in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the ten
clips had the biggest impact on you and
why what change you're going to make as
a result of watching this video leave it
in the comments and I will join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Patricia Rambo Letty
thank you so much for pre-ordering my
book it means a lot to me it means the
world to me for those of you who want
your chance at a shout out in a future
video you can check out the information
in the description below thank you guys
so much for watching continue to believe
or whatever your one word is and I'll
see you soon
this thing is a long-distance race this
business is a long-distance thing you
want to be relevant you want to be
around you want to be providing for your
family 10 15 20 years from now you just
said JD's got to be 44 he put out his
first time when he's 25 that's 20 years
of relevancy you know and like I was
just so that's what it teaches me being
around all of these guys even uncle Wes
it's like finding this full of wow you
know to me he's been around a game of
basketball for a long time is its
longevity it's not so when I make
decisions whether with single this show
or that show or this tour should I get
on this feature should I take this money
to do this song or should I make my
decisions more calculated about is this
something that's going to be ready like
does this further my career or does this
you know I think about things in that in
that manner what does this do for me in
the long run